but I have to talk about how you're a
part of the Marvel Universe I love
Marvel as well and I love the fact this
juxtaposition you playing such a serious
like cool like historically relevant
film and then also getting into the
Marvel World which I love that world too
so it's just fun to kind of exercise
those different muscles and so you're
caned right I am I am
yes we we are like Marvel people we love
I know no but I love that I love my
favorite thing is when and it's rare
when someone comes on here and you're
doing something that like I said it's
like historically relevant it's really
important that kind of thing but then
you do something super fun and like just
action-packed I think it's awesome to do
do you like I would assume you don't
want to play the same role over and over
so it's kind of fun I'm gonna play a
villain yeah I mean a villain I'm sorry
a super villain he said super yeah
it's amazing it's it's extremely uh
humbling you know and and a lot of fun
and you know
I remember sitting on the incubator uh
at my uh Granddaddy's Farm yeah reading
all the books and my imagination would
go and I would you know play in these
worlds and I never imagined you know or
perhaps I always hoped that I would be
able to do that you know step in the
worlds like that and and again
Kang is definitely a dream come true you
know it's just fun to play a bad guy oh
it's the best yeah it's the best I mean
you get to be a jerk and people love it
and want it who
the more jerkish you are the more they
love you oh my God it's like more yeah
and there's layers to it yeah there's
layers how you got there there's layers
okay to the to the jerk I'm gonna peel
all of them back when I watch it yes
ma'am yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I'm going
[Music]